we are here with a very special guest
Gary welcome to the show a pretty
unfortunate result for you but it seemed
like you are having fun was that the
case yeah maybe I'm having too much fun
um I think there were very high
expectations after my performance last
year here but last year I did some chess
I mean this this year when I arrived
here I just realized that you know I
didn't play chess over the board for a
year and obviously you know the latest
events in Europe you know the war in
Ukraine and this it's it's
uh consume all my energy and attention
and and uh but some games here just made
me feel really good to know okay but of
course of course I wanted to do better
but uh you know looking at these nine
games I would say in six games at least
in six games so this is I missed uh very
good chances so I was better against
Iranian in the end game uh could be even
much better I was winning against
Nakamura I was
at one point winning his Corona I had a
very promising position yesterday that's
that's a game that actually made me
really unhappy because you know I
sacrificed The Exchange you know instead
of playing slightly worse position I
went for complications I probably was
correct evaluation and I knew that
United Texas seven was not the best move
but intuitively but I had no time you
know this and I and I spent precious
minutes you know calculating I saw Rook
should go at least three only four I
wasn't sure where you know so and uh
computer prove that August 3 white was
slightly better still part of a draw but
black had to be very very accurate so 97
then we reach this position I said okay
it's a draw and I managed
I mean how on Earth was
up and two pawns for exchange you know
it's just it's that really yeah it's
it's really bad and um and uh and then
it was Laos game with Mommy out of that
so and actually I was very very uh uh
happy to play the game with Wesley I
think that's who are the most exciting
games we played here the whole
tournament and I did some really good
moves and as I played you know very
energetically and uh and uh it as
computer till says that at one point I
was better it's very close to the end so
instead of Laos book 96 King gate and
the Wesley may not have survived so and
and today also I just I I had very good
positions young very good position and
it's also again it's it's a lack of
practice Yeah you know it's this is you
know what you want with your business D1
anything on D1 it's not as good as on D3
so that's why Bishop city which is a
lousy move because you know what's
happened you know I let him basically do
to bring the knight from C8 and exchange
might not on G3 so then then I just you
know after the game he asked me why that
you're running for apologize for a
second we can't control it for 10 plus
two second increment
we will play the same position in both
games once we finish this game we'll
have a rest for a couple of minutes and
then we'll start game two immediately if
we're still tied at the end of the match
we will go to an Armageddon game which
will be a different position uh we'll
have a drawing of lots immediately and
then you'll both get five minutes to go
over the position before we start the
Armageddon game
it's now time to begin good luck
Gentlemen please go ahead and start
White's clock
Gary I have to ask you one question you
played against alireza from one world
champion to maybe a potential other does
he have what it takes to together well
he definitely you know looks very strong
so it is for his age and I will not be
surprised that you know if he makes it I
mean it's uh by every every count
including H so he's just you know he
might be you know being the real
Contender uh for for the title naturally
he's outstanding performance here in in
this tournament actually in these
tournaments yeah it's just another proof
that he's really good there's a lot to
to to to to do to work on uh
actually speaking they know this is I
would never play Knight to free closing
the bishop on on on on on G1 yeah that's
yeah still still plenty of work today
now that's yeah that's definitely not I
wouldn't recommend maybe that's the
modern way of playing but still I prefer
my vision too to be yeah um so okay I
just you know I I
uh
cherish some memories of this tournament
again I wish to know there's some good
moves I made you know
all over the board during nine games
could be could be made in one or two
games and the blunders you know that
will move to one or two games but again
it's just it happens yes I uh yeah yeah
I have to say that you know it's it's
not recommendable just doing what I did
so I needed to take a bit more seriously
though it was probably impossible uh
these days but
um you know if I if I do it again so I
may uh I may uh change my attitude and
just do a little bit more
um more of uh studies yes
um yeah actually I'm just now as we're
speaking I'm looking at this game
yeah it's an interesting one I guess
because of the D4 I think I think uh at
least I won't play D4 but after A5 it
might be yeah karwan will remind him
that the king is the king
and I was thinking that maybe alireza
wants to go H4 and Bishop page two no no
no the pawn on E5 I think I think I
won't play D4 that's that's what's black
but now you saw him oh he played D4 yeah
before he played D4 yes no that's the
analysis and then A5 but after D4 A5 I
think he saw it now and that's that's
that's that's what he's thinking yeah
oh yeah it's uh maybe yeah you should
yes still I just I I hate Bishop one G1
this is this this is certain things you
know as yes I I would not even consider
playing Knight to free
yeah it's a little bit more you know
emphasis on tactics instant tactics you
know but there's certain
um actually speaking about before you
know with you know was can I give myself
when I just was in symmetry so instead
of playing some lousy moves like 92 I at
one uh in the opening I could have
played before just you know that's why I
didn't play before
we saw you discuss with Ali Reza and it
felt like you almost are giving him some
advice for the future what were you
telling him now look you know again I I
think it is I'm not giving advice I'm
just you know it's always nice to talk
to Darwin young to actually made a good
move C4 yeah some space for the king
yeah it makes space for the king and
it's just he's playing he's playing for
for black skin yes for yes A5 b55 yeah
yeah I think
what Corona will do it's the I think
after King City play C5
so you give the check on a300
no I think you play C5 I mean it's yeah
just you have to press you have to stop
D4 yeah and I think C5 is a natural base
because of the C5 the whole construction
is very odd White Construction so I will
say this is because it was D4 then just
you know his plan is Justified after C5
so not Bishop C5 C5 no oh oh sorry you
can do Bishop of course you know Bishop
C5 Bishop C5 D4 four years yeah but then
you just yeah that's the then you take
taken B6 yes yeah yeah maybe B6
installed next time
he could start with probably B6
attacking E4 plus spreading space
recheck and queen takes E4
I played Bishop C5 which is also good D4
take take maybe Knight D6
then brother then a Fred don't like
University it's t because now white
Bishop somehow will be will be
uh before he's on the board of course
yeah of course on the board yes
so we're most likely going to see take
take
[Music]
you feel Fabiano is having good position
right now
after uh potentially the which point you
want is going to open up after F3 yes
at the same time
but you are losing some material by
force
um can I take on C4 yeah then Queen C3
that's then then then you might be I did
I think Bobby had to do something else
because he just let
uh
yeah I thought it would C5 you know
after C5 yeah I probably had to start
with B6 attacking the Pokemon D4 and
then playing maybe the bishop said just
he could have because then I literally
had to defend the pawn only four not
with D3 maybe exactly no but not with F3
now now we can play a free yeah
still uh a good position for Fabiano and
some pressure
is the flight 96 96 is on the board
they're free now yes
can he go 95 after F3 Maybe try to take
without light that's there and and what
about Knight F5
ah then Bishop A3 check oh that's
important it's a check so you should
start with probably Queen C3 and after
you take on C4 I play Knight F5 and then
take your Bishop yeah well we're going
to find out the answer because F3 is on
the board
because Bishop C4 yeah Bishop C4 take
take Queen C3 is definitely calculating
yeah I'm taking the pawn immediately
Knight to E5 is also
95 was probably the 95 Queen City maybe
D6
just you know not to prepare because yes
the king is just you know just
pretentious yes yes could be could be
made so that's why you want you want to
do something just you know because now
my day five night C6 Bishop S3 check
your check so this doesn't work so
that's why you
yeah sir Anastasia
I think uh Fabi has got an advantage
right out of this position and yeah
Gary all the way I thought that Knight
F3 was terrible maybe there was even a
better way of punishing it even so white
is shedding upon and I I like uh the
position Gary um shaqreer said sometimes
it's very easy to lose with white
because you expect to have an advantage
you come and you make a move like E4 or
D4 in the opening and then you can't
justify and you put your bond too far up
the board with E4 D4 uh did you feel
that you had an advantage as white in
your games
um look it's yeah so it's very good
question because I think after so many
tournaments of 962 who played here in
San Luis maybe you know someone has to
do little analysis here like forensic
analysis because the position is very
uneven some positions you know are
really challenging so for for black for
instance today in round one on two I
think we had positions that are really
good for white so C4 in game one man I
had Big Adventures with Nepal C4 and B4
and the same actually in second round F4
G4 so that's what what Dominguez did and
it's black is just you know black is
under heavy pressure so um
I I think it's it's this maybe maybe we
need you know we need we need to
probably limit number of positions you
know checking with the computer and
basically leading positions that that
are balanced but I agree with shock that
you know it's so easy for white to to go
wrong because you know sometimes you
know moves like E4 or D4 they may
actually lead to to disadvantage because
because of the awkward position of the
of the pieces so um and that's why it's
very often moves at G4 and B4 are the
best so um it's um it's again it's it's
the the beauty of this game is that you
know what uh from move one you have to
think you know and this is and sometimes
you have positions that are just that or
um that have weaknesses you know this
like yesterday was shocked you know I
got so confused with first move because
polon G7 is hanging and then it'll just
started 9g3 yeah yeah but it's it's
actually it's yeah it's not a big deal
because you know I just I simply could
do symmetry because the attack was you
know but I could have sacrificed the
pawn and uh and instead I just I made
actually after e604 black is lost so I
lost since the game with three moves so
uh it's oh Fabi Fabi made a castle
nuts
tucking the king away it's interesting
but it's just I
yeah it's still still pretty pretty
nasty Gary what were you looking at in
these positions when analyzing first
with your team partners uh were you
looking at space Advantage we're looking
at development what was the biggest
factor of assessment that you were
basing your decisions on you know I
think in this this in in this game now
you know space Advantage is very
important uh and uh and that's why you
see so many moves you know the flank
moves A4 B4 G4 H4 so because it's this
is not what happens in In classical jazz
um and I uh it's sometimes again you may
have you know the strong content play in
the center but it's uh it's again it's
very very unbalanced so this is first
few moves are so important so it's it's
because typically now we play at 50 20
moves now you know from move one you
have a very very very precise again
it's uh like you know today you know I I
got big Advantage with white by playing
C4 and B4 and the same happened when I
played against is with F4 G4 and
maybe I could do bad actually at one
point you know I just I I kicked myself
ahead that's after he played H4 I could
have played Knight D4 taking at least
one of his Bishops and creating a little
bit of contemplate and but I just I was
so unhappy with it was him just you know
simply moving you know
I just had to stay you know with my
queen on G8 you know just waiting for
them for the inevitable Gary what's next
for you any uh other tournaments or I
just like look I am and I I know my
limitations and I have so many things to
do now it's the now my next is I go to
Europe now actually tomorrow flight to
New York and and that's that's in the
morning early morning at night go to
Europe so I have several cities to visit
I do lectures and also meet some you
know politicians because it's again it's
uh this is this is a decision moment for
for our civilization and I
I while you know I was unhappy with
what's happened here I was very happy to
see that Ukraine is winning and that's
that's what matters for the humanity not
how many points I I make in the
tournament Gary thank you very much for
joining us and hopefully we'll see you
in let's let's make sure like I'm happy
to to see oh that would be great let's
let's you know because I'm also curious
so what's the what's time control uh
right now is three minutes for Ali Reza
and almost six minutes for Fabiano
doesn't like his kingdom C1 no no that
happens you know when you when you play
before with King on C1 yeah he would
love to Castle short right but there's
three moves to go into you can do that
uh maybe even more than that one two
three four yeah but the problem is you
know C4 Pawn is just it's uh is in big
trouble okay what
what king B2 King B2 he's trying to hide
away A1 I won at least he was only one
was a king
so uh no Now Pawn is ponies upon
how to increase the pressure Knight to
E5 Gary sounds like a natural number
yeah
oh C6 open things up yeah
in five years
now you know the mission statement of uh
the pond grubbers Gary is upon is a pawn
but you know is this yeah I know but uh
how do you take the poem yes sir maybe
slowly
we don't rush we don't rush we're we we
want to make sure that we don't follow
some devilish trick well there's some
Knight of fives coming at some point but
that's what I'm thinking Queen A7 is one
of those moves that really help uh
people like Bishop before Bishop Bishop
before first yeah and then Knight takes
C4 yes
King A1 Bishop B4
going to see two most likely Knight
takes C4 yeah and Google on C1 I think
yes he went all the way to C1 yes
he takes C4 Bishop takes C4 at least he
developed the pieces
take them off at least I take C4
yeah
yeah still is the yeah yeah Bishop goes
on D4 now
Brook
all of a sudden yeah you know Queen on
the 8th that's why that's that's why
that's why I was very cautious in
evaluating King on the eighth of King on
eight so you can just white this white
is playing with extra Queen yep and uh
it's a it's a very serious advantage
well Bishop yeah so do you agree that
Queen is a queen yes Paul there's a pawn
but Queen is a queen
yeah the queen is not uh participating
yeah no Queen is not that's why I think
your Fabi had to do better I mean this
is the he actually found a great idea of
bringing on A1
escaped yeah
and Fabi right now actually falling down
to his last four minutes as well
definitely feeling the pressure
Rook takes D7
you'd like to maintain this as for as
long as you can no
this uh okay all right it's probably
correct move
provocative move she takes
simplify things I think that pawn was
taking off
he goes he goes into attack he goes for
kill Knight takes you seven Bishop takes
step six
take only four Bishop takes F6 maybe
that's uh
I'm not sure gf6 because yeah
yeah without with extra Queen you can do
many many nice things many nice things
yeah when you have an extra queen I'm
very strong very strong no uh I'm
feeling the heat Bishop F6 Queen H6
Knight G7 as you say Gary
Bishop F6 uh maybe take on e4 you take
on F6 and now I go Bishop G6 but no the
Knight on C4 is sagging
that's why he went Bishop G6 first
just to stop these ideas of Knight G7
and Bishop F6
G3
and there was your kid I know okay I
know the kids
he's adding pressure yeah Knight G3 now
now
I don't know maybe C5 yes Knight
something to be said for C5 97 check
then yeah
but okay it's not the end of the world
and then yeah yeah this is yes well C5
is very natural
because that now you start
putting your piece into play exactly
that's the big problem
eight eight
yes yes
he wants to bring the queen
d8 is going to be a great defender
sorry Rosa has to do something fast and
the times Anastasia yeah really but it's
still a little bit too tickling yes H4
140 one one and a half minutes for
alireza yeah
C5 he has to go C5 yeah okay because
it's not just you open the position C5
because okay H5 King is protected so the
C5 is important C5 bc6 bc6 and then you
know just another another C5 if
necessary so also C5 secures the Knight
on C4 bc6 bc6 neither CQ yeah yeah so
you don't have to worry anymore about
the Knight and then you can start doing
other things
E6
yeah but that's you know that's the I
want to play C5 without even thinking
yeah yeah so
so now at least why cannot take on D5
anymore because Knight is hanging Fabi
is being very practical with his clock
his yes he's H5 H5 Bishop 595 Queen is
six 26. because otherwise the command
takes a certain might be a threat yes
what just happened Gary
no King just so in H5 he wants to play
okay
and I said you know black had to I
couldn't waste time so he wasted time
can you do 7h5 is that enough though you
cannot go Bishop F7 because of Queen G5
check no that might be a problem
so why are you just wasted time
and now he wants to take on G6 and then
Knight H5 check
and that's the Rook H1 Knight H5 things
are getting murky yeah yeah
Bishop B6 take on Rook H1 yes
Bishop D6 no yeah it's the six on Rook
H1
definitely H5
still probably not saving the Rook H5
yes h8 Queen G5 I feel all three results
he wasn't winning
you think white is winning
Fabiano needs a good move yeah that's
why play C5 you know Play Active moves
well one thing Rook H1 will allow Bishop
D2 so we have a Tempo to do something oh
okay
we have a Tempo to do something I am not
sure what I'm supposed to do though am I
supposed to play I don't know Queen E6
uh like 26 on to take that use the piece
ag6 85. now ages six first and then 85
yes yeah yeah
gotta take back because the bishop takes
F6 that's a problem again I suggest C5
yeah C5 still no no no C5 then he can do
take take a knight H5 check yeah so
nice and he's playing Knight to E5
closing up that diagonal that seems like
and very quickly came an answer I'm not
sure what it was no there he comes
second G6 take on G6
we're expecting yeah
Reza really wants to open up that
diagonal
C5 yes
C5
no play C5 he will never play C5 it's
oh my gosh C5 yeah so C5 was a good V6
Knight C6 but finally
I'm sure that's the right that's a good
moment right now the moment missed was
missed see if we change the Queens tame
the position
something tells me is not good no do you
take it back Bishop D4 now is just as a
killer king yes
King has a very very strong indication
it's all gone A3
South A3
a39 seconds Rook takes b72 93.
and what's the clock time sorry
Anastasia 23 seconds again 15 seconds
guys
and just to remind everybody this is the
first of two games they're switching
colors for game two in these playoffs
he's a killer Okay Jade trying to cover
up the H1 oh my gosh clock times 11
seconds
okay it's completely winning for white
but
foreign
by the way there's only two seconds
increment not five ah yes maybe they
forgot about it no they didn't no no two
seconds
Knight C2 on Tab and he's done it oh
that's good that's gonna be amazing
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
so I think 51
it's actually
yeah four out of four so far wow we're
not worthy we're not worthy you're oh
you're still not over it's still not
very